you can nail the perfect premise sign a
great cast hire the right director but
you can't avoid the simple truth that
some movies are a lot less than the some
of their parts the romantic comedy Aloha
was supposed to Mark a winning return to
form for Cameron Crowe the Oscar winning
writer and director who had us at hello
in the 9s with Jerry Maguire Aloha had
so much going for it too a Scenic
setting a sweet plot and an A-list cast
that included The undeniably Lovable
Emma Stone but all was not well between
accusations that Crow had whitewashed
the diverse face of Hawaii limited
pre-release access for reviewers and a
studio head who privately disliked
everything about the film from the GetGo
the movie landed at the box office with
Ault thud and never recovered the total
gross amounted to a sad $26 million
leaving it more than $10 million shy of
earning back its budget after Tim
Burton's aliceon Wonderland became a
billion dooll hit at the box office a
sequel was a foregone conclusion the
thinking being that even without Burton
at the helm audiences would pay to see
Johnny Depp romping around Wonderland a
second time have you any idea why a
raven is like a writing desk but despite
an ensemble cast of aists and just as
much mad Hattery as the first film Alice
Through the Looking Glass failed to
replicate the magic of its predecessor
it earned a poultry $27 million on
opening weekend domestically the first
movie had over four times that the wrer
by critics as a Lazy Hollow retread
Alice Through the Looking Glass was
overshadowed by both the simultaneous
release of X-Man apocalypse and a
scandal surrounding its leading man as
Depp soon to be ex-wife Amber herd
alleged that the actor had physically
abused her in the Golden Age of reboots
it was only a matter of time until
someone made a CGI heavy summer
blockbuster out of the classic Chariot
racing drama benur based on a novel that
had been adapted no fewer than five
times benur had a $100 million budget
and a promising premise the sweeping
epic history of gladiator mashed up with
the edge of your seat action of the Fast
and the Furious Al last where previous
benur had been big successes at the box
office this one tanked variety declared
it the biggest bomb of the summer after
an $ 11.4 million opening weekend and
later reported that the film had cost
MGM a write down of $48
million it's hard to believe that a
movie as notorious as Catwoman was once
supposed to be a huge hit but in 2004
dressing up Academy award-winning actor
Holly Barry like a butt stomping feline
dominatrix sure seemed like a recipe for
raking in the Box Catwoman was a
character already beloved by Batman fans
superhero flicks were reliable box
office draws and Barry certainly looked
the part what could go
wrong get
over guess what
it's over time as it turned out pretty
much everything the movie apparently
blew all of its $100 million Budget on
leather underwear and CGI cats leaving
nothing left over to pay for things like
say a coherent script ultimately the
movie's domestic gross was an abysmal
$40 million and Barry who showed up in
person to collect a Razzi award for the
film was happy to agree that Catwoman is
a creative equivalent of a hairball on
the carpet although movies based on true
life disasters can be hit or Miss
Hollywood had every reason to believe
that they had a winner on their hands
with deep water Horizon the movie had a
premise that was made for the big screen
and a star Mark Walberg with a solid
history of well performing movies but
where wallberg and director Peter Berg
were able to make a sleeper hit of Lone
Survivor their far more expensive
reunion and deep waterer Horizon
couldn't capture that same box office
magic whether due to poor marketing
choices a bloated budget or the negative
connotations of the words deep water
Horizon the movie was one of the biggest
flops of the year in the US it brought
in a disappointing domestic grow of
$61.44 million in total the worldwide
numbers improved the picture bringing
the total take to $121 million but with
marketing cost taken into account it
still added up to a rare and expensive
misfire for ber and Wahlberg in 2016
with a number of female Le movies raking
in the millions Hollywood had every
reason to believe an all Lady reboot to
the classic Ghostbusters franchise would
turn out to be a veritable Cash Cow the
fact that it acted as a reunion between
bridesmaid director Paul feed and stars
like Melissa McCarthy and Kristen wig
only sweetened the deal as did the
involvement of Kate McKinnon and lesie
Jones despite a Title Wave of Buzz and a
little controversy the publicity failed
to translate into dollars at the box
office the movie cost $144 million for
production alone and would have needed a
worldwide gross of $300 million to break
even sadly it didn't even come close the
final worldwide gross was just $229
million nowadays Green Lantern is
remembered as such a notorious loser
that even star Ryan Reynolds couldn't
resist using it as a punchline in his
other far more successful superhero
flick ladies and gentlemen I give
you me Deadpool back in 2011 however the
movie seemed like a sure thing for many
of the same reasons that Deadpool did
namely Ryan Reynolds and skin tight
spandex playing a lesser known comic
book superhero who opened up fun and
exciting possibilities for expanding the
DC Universe sadly this formula fizzled
and critics were not charitable with
their assessments Green Lantern had a
decent opening weekend but for a film
that cost $200 million for production
alone it's $219 million worldwide take
was a huge
disappointment audiences Love Steve
Carell which is almost certainly what
Hollywood was thinking when they threw
$175 Million worth of production money
at Evan Almighty a sequel to the
infinitely more successful Jim Carrey
movie Bruce Almighty this movie gave
Carell supporting character from that
film his turn in the Spotlight by and
large this was supposed to be a
crowd-pleasing summer comedy the whole
family could enjoy unfortunately Carell
was working with a lackluster script and
a ludicrously expensive cast of CGI
wildlife and not even his considerable
charms could floto film critics derided
for being preachy and unfunny a late
summer push got Eman Almighty past the
100 million dollar Mark but that was a
small victory against its overall
shortfall with a familiar fairy tale at
its Center and a blockbuster director at
a Helm Brian Singer Jack the Giant
Slayer should have been a solid money
maker at the box office at the very
least in fact the film was so readily
expected to be a success that even the
folks who analyze movie flops for a
living struggle to explain its dismal
performance was it the March release
State the lack of a franchise tie-in
nobody really knows whatever the reason
Jack did so badly out of the gate that
pundit immediately compared it to John
Carter which suffice to say was not good
news Warner Brothers reportedly pumped
close to $200 million into the CGI
Adventure plus another $100 million for
marketing with a global gross of $197
million poor Jack ended up more than
$100 million in the whole the long
strange Saga of Dwayne Johnson and Black
Adam stretches back more than 15 years
the wrestler turned movie star first
announced his intention to play the DC
Comics anti-hero in 2007
sh over the years the project grew and
mutated gaining and shedding directors
existing in a kind of Perpetual limbo
meanwhile Johnson became one of the
Century's most recognizable and bankable
Leading Men and superhero movies became
a license to print money but when these
two Unstoppable box office forces
finally combined in October 2022 and
actually went pretty badly black Adam
fared well enough overseas but only
grossed $168 million in the US which for
today's topheavy tent pole releases
marked a serious disappointment if not
an outright disaster so what happened
well the film was caught in a perfect
storm of Shifting cultural Trends in
corporate drama the covid-19 pandemic
had forced delays in filming and the
release date was pushed back from July
2022 to October to accommodate health
concerns about large indor Gatherings
but after postponing for 4 months
audiences were still understandably shy
about packing multiplexes for character
they didn't already know and love even
for hardcore Comics fans the film was
Dead on Arrival as it was clear that the
new Warner Brothers Discovery regime was
uninterested in maintaining the old dceu
continuity sure enough two months after
the film's release Johnson released a
statement confirming that there would be
no Black adom
2 Martin scorsese's 2011 family film
Hugo was a critical success appeared on
over two dozen best of lists at the end
of the year and won five Oscars it's a
technical Marvel and a tribute in both
Form and Function to the magical days of
of early Cinema from one of the medium's
true Masters it was also an utter box
office bomb not even the premium charge
for 3D tickets could save it originally
budgeted at $100 million the cost of
creating scorsese's dream world version
of 1930s Paris soared north of $150
million and made less than half that in
US theaters and while the trailers
promise a Fantastical kids adventure
with the aonomus Hugo living in the
walls of a train station the actual film
is more concerned with the spiritual
Rehabilitation of real life Cinema
Pioneer George mes perhaps this subject
was a bit too esoteric for families who
had plenty of other options at the
multiplex at Thanksgiving weekend from
the Muppets to Puss and
Boots talk of a fifth Indiana Jones
movie started not long after the release
of the fourth 2008 smash Blockbuster hit
Indiana Jones in the Kingdom of the
Crystal Skull but it would take another
15 years for Indiana Jones in the dial
of Destiny to see the light of day it's
not the
years it's the mileage when the movie
finally hit theaters in July 2023 it
came with a new studio in Disney a newor
director in James Mangold and a
reportedly gigantic $300 million budget
plus another $100 million on top for
marketing costs there would seem to be
no sure bet in Hollywood than a new
Indiana Jones movie and yet dial of
Destiny faced a surprisingly steep
uphill battle details of the plot were
kept top secret which allowed inaccurate
rumors about Phoebe Waller Bridge's
character replacing Indie to flourish
among the reactionary wing of Indie
fandom then the film premiered at the
can film festival a full 5 weeks before
opening in theaters and a tepid
reception there quickly Lowered
Expectations for its domestic release
dial of Destiny endured a $60 million
opening weekend in the states and
although the overall critical response
has been Kinder than can the film's
bloated budget and underperformance at
the box office have doomed it to be
little more than a footnote movie
history who's to blame when a movie
flops there are dozens if not hundreds
of variables that weigh on a film
success or failure and the quality of
the film itself is sometimes the least
important if you ask Ridley Scott
however the blame for his 2021 medieval
epic the last duel Falls squarely and
solely on the backs of those darn
Millennials and their phones after the
film opened fifth at the box office
behind a string of franchise hits he
told Mark Marin the millennian do not
ever want to be taught anything unless
you are told it on the cell phone back
in 2019 the last duel seemed like a hot
commodity a real life tale of 14th
century Justice whose themes of sex
power and patriarchy made it a perfect
fit for the me too era Matt Damon and
Ben Affleck were set not only to Star
but script together for the first time
since Goodwill Hunting alongside
filmmaker Nicole hallof Center affle
eventually took a smaller supporting
role and Adam dri stepped in as the
younger lead delayed nearly a year by
the pandemic the film sank like a stone
at the box office but later found its
audience on home video and streaming
maybe Scott was right after all is 2021s
and Matrix resurrections yet another
example of Studios shamelessly strip
mining their IPs for parts and cashing
in on millennial Nostalgia or is it a
harsh criticism of exactly that offered
up by a filmmaker with nothing to
lose I'm sure you can understand why our
beloved parent company Warner Brother
has decided to make a sequel it's likely
both director and co-writer Lana wowski
took a bitterly meta route with the
fourth Matrix movie crafting a world in
which both the Matrix and the Matrix
exist and where the corpses of Neo and
Trinity have literally been pieced back
together in order to provide Power for
the machine's failing infrastructure
back in the real world the film fought
its own battle with the unintended
consequences of a runaway technology
streaming at the height of the pandemic
Warner Brothers instituted a
simultaneous release policy wherein
theatrical films would be available on
HB Max for the first 30 days of release
for resurrections the result of the
strategy was disastrous and the movie
suffered a $10 million opening weekend
on just over 3,500 screens it was so bad
in fact that producers Village Road Show
Entertainment sued Warner Brothers for
breach of contract claiming that the
studio intentionally gutted the film's
box office in order to increase end ofe
streaming subscriptions resurrections
would go on to gross just $157 million
worldwide against the reported $190
million budget and in the 2 years since
its release there has been practic
ically no talk of another sequel of all
the attempts to recreate the success of
the MCU over the last decade or so the
one that made the most sense on paper
was Universal's so-called Dark Universe
which would have rebooted the studio
stable of classic movie Monsters sadly
Universal's first attempt at
kickstarting a monster verse 2014's
Dracula Untold was unsuccessful then
they tried again 3 years later with the
mummy an ungainly Beast of a film about
an army officer who accidentally awakens
a vengeful Undead Egyptian princess and
discovers an entire world of
Supernatural threats in an extreme case
of putting the cart before the horse
Universal announced an entire slate of
Dark Universe pictures including remakes
of the Invisible Man starring Johnny
Depp and Bri of Frankenstein with jav ar
bardam and Angelina Jolie Russell Crow's
Dr Henry Jackal would be the Nick Fury
like connecting tissue between the films
leading up to the inevitable Avengers
style Monster Mash alas it was not to be
as the mummy was a critical and
Commercial failure collapsing into dust
at the box office and taking the entire
Dark Universe down with it years later
All That Remains of this experiment in
corporate huis are the Dark Universe
social media accounts which still
tragically promise the Gods and Monsters
to come as Co spread across the world in
2020 prompting quarantines and
prohibitions against large public
Gatherings movie studios had a tough
choice to make about the films they had
scheduled for release should they push
the entire slate back hoping that public
health conditions improve do they hold
back their biggest releases and let
smaller films played to mostly empty
theaters or do they keep those big films
on the calendar in hopes of luring
audiences out of their homes most
Studios opted to play releases or
premere them via streaming especially
after the underperformance of
Christopher Nolan's tenant in August of
that year every Nolan film was an event
but tenant was a vener than most a
massive spy versus spy with time travel
action flick chalk full of men in
stylish suits exploding airplanes and
reams of gibberish Exposition how would
you like to
die old you chose the wrong profession
the film was made to be seen on the
biggest screen possible but arrived at a
moment when people's lives depended on
staying home ten was delayed from June
to late August due to health concerns
but the decision to release theatrically
at all was met with controversy actor
Seth Rogan whose own film and American
pickle went direct to streaming joked to
The Hollywood Reporter at the time that
Nolan seemed intent on killing his
greatest fans in the end the film
flapped at the box office earning just
$58 million in the US and its failure
was a stark message to the rest of
Hollywood if Christopher Nolan couldn't
get Butts back in the seats there was
little hope for anyone else watching the
three trailers released for Brad Bert's
20 5 Adventure tomorrow land it's clear
that Disney knew it had made a visually
striking film but had no idea how to
sell it each preview is by turns of
Peter Pan riff a Chosen One save the
world narrative and a crackerjack action
adventure all of these elements are in
place in the film but what struck
audiences and critics was its all
consuming earnestness about believing in
the future a w iyed sincerity that
crossed over from corny into actively
embarrassing marketing was strong enough
to earn tomorrow land the number one
spot at the box office over Memorial Day
Weekend edging past Pitch Perfect 2 but
its Fortune's quickly faded and in the
end the movie gross just $90 million
domestically against a budget of $190
million once critics and pundit had seen
the film much of the discourse was about
its allegedly IR Rand for kids ethos
while ber has always denied that the
movie features any libertarian bands
it's hard to look at tomorrow land
itself a far away land where Visionaries
can ply their genius away from the
ignorant opinions of ordinary people and
not see a disneyfied version of going
G Warren batty has accomplished a lot in
his seven decade career and he's gotten
away with even more but it hasn't all
gone well and no doubt some setbacks are
harder to get past than others take Town
and Country a long gestating boondoggle
of a middle-aged romantic comedy that
sank like a stone when it was released
in April 2001 the tale of an aging
lothario juggling the many women in his
life that reportedly spent much of its
$90 million budgets on securing its aess
cast the new line Cinema must have had
high hopes for the film when production
began in 1998 by the time it stumbled
into theaters 3 years later they had
lost all confidence Town and Country re
opened at a dismal seventh place at the
box office trailing far behind its
competitors director Peter chelum
survived the debacle at least and went
on to helm hits like the holiday romcom
Serendipity bat meanwhile took a break
from film making he wouldn't appear back
on the big screen until the 2016 Howard
Hughes biopic rules don't apply he's a
red P sick you're so fluffy you're so
fluffy I've always wanted a tail when it
comes to flops and failures numbers
don't always tell the whole story
massive box office take might actually
turn out to be a failure if the movie
costs tooo much to make or a dismal box
office gross on paper might only be half
the picture Pixar's 2022 Coming of Age
film turning red about a Chinese
Canadian girl who transforms into a
giant red panda took in a $20 million
worldwide box office total but what that
number doesn't tell us is that the movie
was never theatrically released in the
US or any other country that has access
to Disney plus after debuting two Pixar
films on the streaming platform in 2021
Disney initially planned for turning red
to be Pixar's return to theatrical
distribution however the Omicron variant
surged at the end of 2021 scuttled those
plans and writer director dumi shi's
feature debut became a Disney plus
original instead so there's a pretty big
asterisk on the film's disastrous box
office Hall but does that make it a
secret hit the world of streaming
viewership ratings is notoriously vague
and untrustworthy companies such as
Netflix apple and Disney will tout
successes and hide failures using
metrics that are difficult to translate
it's worth pointing out that turning red
was the number one streamed film of its
debut week according to Nelson's
rankings of AD supported streaming with
a reported 1.7 billion minutes watched
but how that translates to the
theatrical experience of audience is
actually watching a movie from beginning
to end is anyone's guess after sneaking
musical numbers into a number of his
earlier movies Steven Spielberg finally
took his shot at one of the most popular
movie musicals of all time Westside
Story playright Tony Kushner adapted
Leonard Bernstein and Steven sonheim
1957 Romeo and Juliet riff about Waring
New York street gangs it emphasized the
Sharks Puerto Rican Heritage and place
their conflict with the white jets in
the context of a rapidly gentrifying
mid-century Manhattan the film was
widely acclaimed by critics nominated
for seven Oscars including best picture
and one best supporting actress for
Ariana deo's Fierce turn as Anita but no
one went to see it whether it was the
surging Omicron variant keeping older
audiences away from theaters a marketing
campaign that deliberately downplayed
that it was a musical star anzel El
gort's 2020 sexual assault allegation or
some mixture of all that movie goers had
little interest in a new Westside Story
after being delayed a full year due to
covid-19 the film opened in December
2021 with a weekend gross of $10.5
million just enough to beat in Kanto for
the top spot the next week however it
was trounced by Spider-Man no way home
Westside Story concluded its theatrical
run with a worldwide gross of just over
$76 million a far cry from its $100
million budget or the estimated $300
million it needed to break even as the
pandemic upended the film industry in
2020 it seemed like any decision was the
wrong one to to delay a film for months
if not a whole year risked irrelevance
to push a film into theaters when
shutdowns were ongoing seemed suicidal
to release a film in theaters and on
streaming at the same time invited its
own host of concerns after Warner
Brothers took a bath on Christopher
Nolan's tenant they took a different
route with the superhero flick Wonder
Woman 1984 the Patty Jenkins Helm sequel
premiered in theaters and on HBO Max on
Christmas Day 2020 I've never wanted
anything more the first Wonder Woman had
become a legitimate phenomenon in 2007
as well as the highest domestically
grossing and best reviewed film of the
so-called DC extended Universe 1984 to
put it mildly was not critics were split
as to whether the movie's brighter more
comedic tone was a breath of fresh air
after the dness of DC snye films or too
goofy to take seriously the film pulled
in just $46 million at the US box office
a stunning 90% drop from the first films
take 3 years earlier but while 1984 was
a disaster in theaters it was a hit at
home HBO Max subscriptions reportedly
doubled at the end of 2020 giving Warner
Brothers the confidence to Premiere its
entire 2021 slate in theaters and on
streaming
simultaneously expectations for Disney's
2018 adaptation of the ya classic A
Wrinkle in Time were high arguably too
high a Time magazing cover profile of
the film's creative team was even titled
Hollywood's Once and Future classic
behind the scenes producer Katherine
hand writer Jennifer Lee and director
Ava duver were calling the shots on
screen the movie featured young actor
storm Reed is Plucky hero me Murray
alongside Mindy King Reese Witherspoon
and Oprah Winfrey as the otherworldly
Mrs W's as well as Chris pin's turn as
M's missing father in the leadup to its
release the film really did feel like a
turning point in Hollywood a big-hearted
patriarchy defying shot across the bow
for the power of women in film making
one of the more pricious aspects of that
patriarchy however is that female Le
films often have to be larger than
themselves and they have to make a
serious impact on the bigger picture for
audiences to really turn out this of
course is something male driven films
rarely have to deal with A Wrinkle in
Time opened at number two at the box
office in March 2018 finishing behind
black panther reviews praised U's heart
and ambition but ultimately found the
film overstuffed and underdone it made
$100 million at the domestic box office
and far it even worse overseas
ultimately A Wrinkle in Time was
estimated to have lost $130 million for
[Music]
Disney